Sony Pictures lifted the review embargo for
its highly-anticipated anti-hero flick Venom
on Tuesday, October 2nd, ahead of its October
5th release date, granting permission to the
fortunate few who saw the film at its world
premiere in Los Angeles to post their spoiler-free
thoughts.
In other words, the reviews are in!
And they're weird.
Bottom line: Many critics thought it was hilarious,
but not quite on purpose, and that it features
an unwelcome throwback feel, as if the MCU
comic book movie renaissance never happened.
The Hollywood Reporter's Todd McCarthy, for
example, thinks that Venom is more black sheep
than Black Panther, writing:
"Venom feels like a throwback, a poor second
cousin to the all-stars that have reliably
dominated the box-office charts for most of
this century."
There's a silver lining, however: Tom Hardy.
Collider's Perri Nemiroff found Hardy typically
charming as Eddie Brock, but wished the film
had more of an edge, writing,
"Significant chunks of Venom don't work at
all but there is some serious charm to the
Eddie/Venom relationship.
Not sure I had the intended reactions to some
scenes but fun is fun even when it's totally
ridiculous, right?
It's too bad they didn't go for the R rating
though."
Nerdist's Hector Navarro felt much the same,
but pointed out that the film kept true to
the source material in portraying Eddie as
a guy with an off-kilter sense of humor, writing,
"Despite some problems [Venom] did right by
its main character [...] People forget that
he's always had a weird sense of humor in
the comics, and that humor is fully on display
in the movie!"
The Verge's Bryan Bishop wrote that Hardy
gave a fully fleshed-out, "capital-P performance"
as Venom, writing,
"Hardy is always watchable, no matter the
role, but there's so much to take in here
that it almost feels like he's putting on
a one-man show."
Echoing that sentiment, Uproxx senior entertainment
writer Mike Ryan said he was, quote, "fascinated
with Venom," mostly because while the rest
of the cast was in a dark superhero movie,
Hardy was decidedly not.
Ryan tweeted,
"[Hardy is] basically remaking Jim Carrey's
Liar Liar.
I kinda loved watching this movie, in a Rocky
Horror type of way."
Oh, I have a parasite.
Good night, Mrs. Chen!"
One of the harshest reactions to Venom came
from IGN's Tom Jorgensen, who wrote,
"Sorry to say that Venom is pretty much a
complete failure a tonal mess that feels 15
years old, ignoring the storytelling strides
that the superhero genre has made in recent
years."
MCU Cosmic's Jeremy Conrad kept his critique
simple but biting, sharing a tweet that references
part of a line Venom snarls in one of the
film's trailers.
"Like a turd.
In the wind."
Freelance comics journalist Meg Downey delivered
perhaps the most interesting response to Venom,
calling it an "excruciatingly surreal experience"
and likening it to Ben Affleck's Daredevil,
Ang Lee's Hulk, and Halle Berry's Catwoman
not exactly great company.
Downey wrote in one tweet,
"The humor, the story beats, everything right
down to the Eminem theme song feels like it
emerged Kimmy Schmidt-style from a sealed
off early-'00s bunker."
All in all, the reviews indicate that viewer
mileage will vary wildly with Venom, putting
it just ahead of other franchise non-starters
like the disastrous Universal outing The Mummy.
But Owen Gleiberman of Variety thinks it might
not be enough:
"This gateway into the Sony Universe of Marvel
Characters […] may not sputter as badly
as Tom Cruise's The Mummy, but it could turn
out to be a similar case of a franchise kickoff
that doesn't fully attain franchise liftoff."
But if it does well enough at the box office,
the planned Venom trilogy could indeed become
a reality, and all signs indicate the franchise
is primed to improve with each installment,
leading up to fingers crossed a potential
Spider-Man crossover.
Or at least a substantial appearance by Venom's
rival, Carnage, if and spoiler alert! those
early reports about the mid-credits scene
prove correct.
Make your own call October 5th, when Venom
hits theaters nationwide.